you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens welcome back to the game
spot co-op stage brought to you by lego
star wars the force awakens i'm jeff
cannata from the dlc podcast and
tomorrow daily and i'm joined by let's
be honest a couch full of heroes yes
thank you finally someone recognized
this all stars uh Dave Jewett danio dire
are you doing Ashley's gather uh you
guys it's III I know it's happening it's
day one and it feels like it's day 15 oh
yeah everyone's done press conferences
we've been here since day minus one oh
yeah oh yeah maybe the days keep going
into the negative column and they keep
adding new ones yeah it's crazy but
there's so much stuff to be excited
about here because I got the chance to
sit in a host E chair yeah I got the
chance to say I want to talk about VR
right because i love VR so let's talk a
little bit about VR for the next next
few minutes playstation vr of course is
the one that had the most presence in
the press conferences sure what are your
feelings about playstation vr have you
guys had a chance to try it are you
excited I mean PlayStation VR is really
making the biggest headway as they've
already think they've got it bundled
with a console Xbox talks about VR
accessibility but have not really told
us yeah what they're gonna bundle it
with the most exciting things that I'm
looking forward to is as terrified as i
am with horror games playing a horror
game NVR might just be the deep end that
i need to actually scare myself into
liking horror game and the errata nose
looks like I feel like personal reality
everyone talks about that killer app
right yeah Mikey talking about Resident
Evil I can be a killer up but I also
feel like they place their white you're
talking three hundred and you know
ninety nine dollars go PlayStation be or
either they need that one killer app or
they just need enough good game yeah
that you've got this library it's like
you know that second year the consoles
there and you're like okay now I'm gonna
buy how the games are here yeah so I
think what they were very somebody we're
very bright at the
their press conference because
essentially what they were going to
doing was like here's the game here's
the game here's the game here's the game
and I think that's going to make it an
easier by for people when there's that
library okay yeah yeah we were saying
you know they got Batman and they got a
star wars in VR if you can't sell
something with Batman in Star Wars it
can't be sold right I mean resident evil
looks amazing I got to go to the
showcase last night with you it do psv
our stuff and not only are there some
really good kind of triple-a familiar
faces or familiar franchises we also
have I hear they lie which is gonna be
for me a really good stopgap while I'm
waiting for resident evil that's gonna
come out around launch and I'll scare
myself to death and maybe I won't
actually ever get to play resident evil
because I'll need a lot of therapy but I
think I heard your scream all the way
across the convention center I am
genuinely concerned that I'm gonna end
up in the next sort of like player
trailer because I looked up in the
middle of playing it and it looked like
they have the PlayStation camera going
with the recording i'm like 'oh scream
so loud at that rap man there was a wrap
guys there's a wrap men happening and
here here they look like Batman no rat
men Oh Rat Man half red half man chasing
you with a tire iron it's really scary
stuff do it well fun though so we all
agree that having a big numbered
historic franchise like resident evil on
a on a VR launch window is a great thing
sales wise but how do you guys feel from
you know a love of the franchise wise
like it's a very big departure from what
resident evil has been is it worth it I
mean I hope so it's it's just adding
another element of fear I think like
people play these games to be scared and
it's almost as if horror game after
horror game you kind of get used to the
feeling of being terrified and this this
is a huge step up I mean I've seen
people play project kitchen which was
obviously the backbone of this and have
panic attacks yeah so having a whole
game of this is just going to it's
almost like wiping the slate clean it's
like okay if you if you stopped being
scared of Resident Evil games oh do we
have something for you hey it's an
interesting aspect to it because
obviously this is also going to come out
on
playstation 4 without BR we haven't seen
that yet but the fact that you it's not
just this addendum to the game it's not
just the same mode which a lot of other
games are doing it's like oh no you can
actually play this entire experience
through using virtuality and so they're
kind of getting both fans there they're
allowing the purists who want to play
whatever Resident Evil this is just to
play it the way it was originally
created and then also the bureau one but
you also have to remember resident evil
is not exactly in a great place right
now right resident evil 6 was awful it
needs a boost president 5 was a third
person action game it was pretty far
removed Reggie for was a masterpiece but
they need a light to light a fire
underneath this franchise so and this is
this is not even a talking about rezzy
I'm we've already forgotten a bit sick
so they've done a good job yeah yeah no
it's to get anyone to forget about that
is miracle in and of itself oh it's good
um no I like to your point I think this
is I've heard so many developers talk
about virtual reality as a new Wild West
for development for games and how when
the PlayStation originally came out
there were a lot of questions about how
what players would be interested in
would they want to move the camera
themselves with the right thumbstick
like this was a very it's weird to think
about that as an argument now because it
seems so natural but they're doing the
same things in BR and so to see all of
these experimental sort of ideas
happening I mean I know you talked about
an experience in oculus about the where
you're done chain of monster yeah and
it's like that that kind of stuff is
stuff you just don't see and until now
like because it's possible and it makes
sense and so for VR it just feels like
it's this whole new era of gaming cuz
it's adding another dimension to your
play which is really cool and they're
starting to figure some of this stuff
back yeah what we're seeing is like
there's a there are rule sets that we're
starting to see in somebody's games yeah
and that's what makes it very exciting
as well yeah I was just having a
conversation with the Crytek guys who
are showing Robinson the journey y-yeah
and you know there's a Crytek guys right
they make far cry they make they made
prices right these are the they're known
for shooters and they said you know
everybody's coming up to us and going
well why aren't you making a shooter and
they said well we could if we certainly
could and it'll probably be fun
but here's this new technology that lets
us make completely different kinds of
games that right offer experiences that
you just don't have on a 2d surface
share an exploration that you actually
feel like you're in something and you
look down and around it it it really is
a new kind of way to game yeah it's it's
it's weird that like the walking
simulator thing happened right before VR
cuz they're like made for each other
yeah yeah totally it's interesting you
mentioned prior tech because like they
made rise and original rise Kinect game
yes today and they figured okay this is
gonna work much better as just a brawler
so it's kind of like they're thinking
okay let's not play this by the numbers
let's just make something good that will
work for what we have right and the
biggest appeal to VR for me is having
that sense of exploration seeing these
open-world ceiling all these cool things
exploring them from a new a new depth
finding these amazing picturesque worlds
and getting to go through them whether
it's walking simulator whether it's
something a little more like nice and
tight just let me see them and let me
explore them for myself right yeah i
just had todd howard upstairs and we
were talking about fall NVR right i said
one of the weirdest things is watching
people he said he used to watch twitch
streams of people playing Fallout and he
just enjoyed the parts he said people
talk about the game when they're
shooting but actually most of that game
is spent just ambling around and looking
around like it's like purpose bill
friend right yeah ya know and I love
that I mean that's what I'm most excited
about and that's an example of an
existing game in existing genre that I
think is really going to be you're gonna
benefit from a sense of presence because
you want to feel like you live in those
worlds I want to feel like I'm in Skyrim
I'm in you know the fallout worlds and
they do as much as they can to create
that sense of first-person presence
where they put your bit boy on your hand
and nice yeah and so now we have a
technology that lets it actually feel
like it's on my hand right and I had a
chance to play the fallout 4 V our demo
that they had survived it at their
presentation and it's a little clunky
right now you still the way you move in
the world is through teleportation which
is a way to mitigate the the nausea
factor and that works great but I think
it still has a ways to go to fit
perfectly but it's amazing to be able to
hold that pit boy up and
do you think that playing fallout 4 in
virtual reality will cause you to make
different choices as the hero because
you put yourself more into the character
that's an interesting question i don't
know i mean i always put myself in the
character when i'm playing those
bethesda games anyway I'm like I don't
want to be an a-hole let's be nice as we
can uh anybody looking for a free
dissertation idea you're welcome yeah
yeah I always trying to figure out a way
to like be nice to the to the foundation
people that are you know trying to make
a better tomorrow and also save all the
surface dwellers and I it's a hard you
know I try to just be the nicest guy
like he reflects looking at people like
this like having that conversation with
them and in fallout will make like that
poor grandmother I kept giving drugs to
yeah Jen take it give it a jam and their
of my army don't worry about my Murphy
I'd have to get your sweet jet from
somewhere else you're gonna have to go
to rehab mama yeah well I'll tell you
this as a person that has a vibe at home
and has an oculus at home and has been
spending a lot of hours and V are
already I really feel like the pace of
virtuality games can be so much slower
right and still fun and still rich and
still dense with it with activity
because I can stand in a fallout world
and just kind of look at stuff and open
a drawer and look inside you know and in
the game when I'm playing it normally I
would just be like xxx okay take all you
know but like just manipulating things
and sticking that in my satchel is gonna
it's fun see that's gonna be a problem
for me because as you know we discussed
this a lot i have a real problem with
getting distracted in open world games
and never actually getting anything done
so now i'll be able to clean up the
apocalypse in the wasteland oh man for
reals do you metrics I'm gonna be the
best janitor in the wasteland yes I got
I got real OCD about my house I like it
but the one thing you couldn't fix is
there were stains everywhere right I bet
in virtuality that's like way more
annoying it's amazing how like you
mentioned like mundane tasks becoming
quite interesting in via so I remember
playing euro truck simulator yeah right
and your little most mundane task of all
exactly you just driving truck obeying
road law
I'm there my head's on wheels and I'm
like it's four hours later and I've
driven to Berlin not it was amazing I
feel like that game's gonna be obsolete
in like two years because of uh
autonomous cars right like when are
those it's gonna feel weird to us to
actually take control of a car in 20
years be like a glamour job yeah yeah
like I wish to have that yeah I get so
you guys are are you guys in on VR I
mean you feeling like are you are you
itching to get your hands on a
PlayStation VR oh boy i pre-ordered day
one playstation vr i was very excited
it's the only thing that i have
compatible with a headset right now my
playstation 4 um and I was worried at
first and then after yesterday I said I
am in I'm really excited now I'm glad
that I did it because I would I think I
would have been bummed if I would have
not done it and then seeing everything
yesterday like I saw psychonauts rhombus
and rhombus of ruin like all that stuff
ma'am I'm so glad that I'm gonna to play
like right on octobre 13 it's a bit of a
bummer for me who owns an oculus and a
vibe that I'm staring down the barrel of
buying a third a headset now because we
and not because we have these these
exclusives and it I mean this is a
display technology right it's like it's
like a benq monitor having an exclusive
title you know it's a little bit weird
to me but yeah I think that's the
biggest problem still is that the cost
of any one of these individually is a
lot of money i mean like people you save
up for months to buy a console and why
you're talking about is you know even
the cheapest version of this if you get
the playstation 800 your ring well that
weld acc vibes around there the
playstation vr ii to get from foreign
gbox have a console right and you have
to have to move control a hundred bucks
for those I'm the camera 60 bucks for
that I lepton 499 for the pack right so
the whole all land it's 499 and then and
then if you don't have a PlayStation so
349 let's say for holiday so it's about
the price of a pc headset well yeah I
cost more than those diggle diggle say
that you're holding out for the trucking
simulator for Vibe well maybe I'll baby
get in when I can't get it because the
biggest ham permit for me is because I
live it like a quaint London flat it's
just my face like I would love to have a
vibe but I be like clatter into shells
falling all over my
an extra two thousand and rims yeah
exactly i'd have to up my rent and then
repair all the stuff that i've broken
because I'm smashing into everything I
mean for me vibe would be the one I'd
get but if you're looking if you're if
you're in like a cramp situation like I
am it seems the PlayStation VR will
probably the best for a few so it's
almost as if your lifestyle and your
living arrangement is defining your VR
choice yeah that's very very good point
and I'm very impressed with the
PlayStation VR visual quality it has a
cracked screen it has actually less of
that screen door effect then the vibe
has so lots to be excited about with VR
we're going to be back talking about
more stuff from the coop stage so stare
it stay glued to whatever screen you see
us on I'll be right back